So I'm sitting here
starting to wrap gifts for my kids for the holiday season,
because I like to be on top of it,
and because we're probably gonna be traveling soon,
and we have guests coming in, and, like,
I just wanna get it done. Okay.
We also do Christmas, Hanukkah,
and then I have. My third child's birthday is on the 27th.
And this is kind of a question for people who have December babies,
but especially holiday area babies.
This is the first year that he knows,
I guess, what his birthday is.
He's turning three,
and I think we could get away without doing a big party this year.
But I wanna know how people
in the past, people with December birthdays or December babies
have made it really special for them.
And I understand, like,
this year is a complete chaos
because Hanukkah starts on Christmas,
so that means there will be Hanukkah on his birthday no matter what.
And I have a feeling that'll happen again in his lifetime
because Hanukkah changes every year.
But considering Hanukkah is gonna be on his birthday,
sometimes on his birthday this year,
Christmas is two days before,
how can I still make his birthday like,
a big deal? Because we.
We tend to do pretty big birthdays in our house.
Not huge, but we definitely love celebrating.
We take any excuse to celebrate.
And before anyone asks, yes,
we have birthday wrapping paper for the birthday presents.
I do know that that's a big deal